premier débat du conseil européen est
sans doute le plus important le plus
regardé celui qui a porté sur la
reconnaissance du statut de candidat à
cordes et donc à l'ukraine vous l'avez
rappelé mais aussi à la moldavie en
revanche pas à la géorgie qui est le
troisième pays qui avait soumis sa
candidature il ya maintenant quelques
semaines mais une perspective européenne
a été reconnue à ce troisième pays avec
l'idée que si un certain nombre de
conditions sont remplies notamment en
matière d'apaisement de la situation
politique intérieure de réformes liées à
l'état de droit en particulier il
pourrait y avoir
une reconnaissance du statut de candidat
mais cette décision n'a pas été prise à
l'occasion du sommet européen et donc
c'est évidemment le cren mais aussi la
moldavie qui ont fait l'objet de
l'attention plus spécifique des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement la moldavie
parce que vous le savez c'est un pays
qui n'est
aujourd'hui pas dans l'union européenne
mais qui est nouveau à notre voisinage
immédiat avec une menace et une pression
russe qui n'est malheureusement pas un
cas d'école et qui s'est renforcé encore
avec l'invasion de l'ukraine et les
risques de déstabilisation se sont aussi
accrues en raison d'un stand de
conséquences de ce conflit notamment l
accueil massif de réfugiés pour
lesquelles la france et l'union
européenne ont apporté d'ores et déjà
une contribution notamment financières
permettant d'assurer le soutien
nécessaire à ce pays qui a aussi
accueilli de prendre la république il y
a quelques jours et vous savez que la
chef de l'état moldave madame st loup
est aussi une pro européenne convaincue
donc je pense qu'il est notre intérêt
géopolitique de soutenir ce pays même si
le processus d'adhésion pour la moldavie
comme pour le cren je les dis et je
l'assumé sera long nécessairement alors
pourquoi vous l'avez rappelé je
m'associe à vos propos monsieur le
président pourquoi il était je crois
important et cette décision a été prise
à l'unanimité d'octroyer le statut de
candidat c'était un signal
c'était un symbole bien sûr c'était
aussi une façon d'éviter je crois un
vide politique ou géopolitique si
l'europe avait fermé la porte pour les
le dos de manière définitive
à l'ukraine nous aurions sans doute
renforcer les signaux encourageants la
russie a renforcé encore son agression
et sa pression nous aurions sans doute
casser un espoir une résistance au sein
du peuple ukrainien et donc je n'ai pas
beaucoup de doutes sur le fait que cette
décision était nécessaire
et tant mieux si nous avons réussi à
faire preuve rapidement d'unité
européenne sur l'octroi de ce statut de
candidat il faut compléter ce propos et
cette décision par un stand d'autres
actions et d'autres axes c'est le sens
c'est un débat qu'on ouvre à la fois du
message très clair aussi sur le fait qu'
il y à une un processus d'élargissement
qui est long qui est exigeant et je
crois qu'on préparait des lendemains qui
déchantent si on ne disait pas la vérité
à cet égard à la fois au peuple
ukrainien et à nos concitoyens francs
france et partout dans l'union
européenne il ne s'agit pas de
considérer que l'adhésion européenne est
une chose facile nous voyons déjà les
difficultés que nous avons à fonctionner
à 27 nous prendrions des risques
immenses à ne pas réformer notre union
européenne ou à accélérer un processus
soit le précipite et puis dans la tente
en complément de cette réflexion et de
ce travail sur l'élargissement c'est le
sens de l'intuition et la conviction
forgée par le pr la république présenté
le 9 mai au parlement européen nous
avons besoin d'un autre forum d'un autre
format c'est l'idée de la communauté
politique européenne qui a fait l'objet
de beaucoup de débats pour être tout à
fait honnête de brut questions parfois
de réserve mais qui on pourra y revenir
au dernier sommet européen le 23 juin au
soir a fait l'objet d'une discussion
importante et d'un accord unanime sur
l'idée de travailler sous présidence
tchèque précisément avec une première
réunion qui aura lieu à prague avant la
fin de l'année à la mise en place de ce
cadre de coopération qui est distinct de
l'union européenne encore une fois dans
le sens il peut soit préparée l'adhésion
ou
assurer une coopération dans l'attentes
l'adhésion ce pourrait être le cas du
cren par exemple mais aussi pour
certains autres pays dans l'expression
évidemment extrêmement différentes
peut-être le royaume uni s'il était
intéressé être un cadre intermédiaire de
coopération qui n'est pas l'union
européenne mais qui nous rapproche
en moins c'est le sens profond de cette
idée qui mérite ce je le dis elle assume
aussi d'être affinés travailler dans la
nature des coopérations le format
géopolitique qui serait retenu le
caractère institutionnel faut-il un
forum un traité qui fonderait cette
communauté tout ça tout cela pardon sont
des questions ouvertes sur lesquels
d'ailleurs il serait sans doute très
utile que nous travaillons comme des
bastions ensemble
j'insiste aussi sur
7 sur cette communauté politique
européenne pour faire un lien avec la
situation des balkans occidentaux
puisque vous l'avez rappelé c'était un
souhait avant le début de la guerre en
ukraine de la présidence française que
d'avoir avant la fin de la présidence
nous avons lancé le 23 juin une réunion
entre les chefs d'état de gouvernement
des vingt-sept et les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des six pays des balkans
occidentaux
c'est encore plus nécessaire après le
déclenchement de la guerre en ukraine et
c'est encore plus nécessaire avec
l'octroi du statut de candidat nous
pourrions donner l'impression d'une
certaine confusion ou sans avoir
finalisé le processus d'adhésion avec
certains pays des balkans occidentaux
sans même avoir donné statut de candidat
à d'autres ans à la bosnie nous aurions
ouvert la porte à l'ukraine donc il faut
remettre les choses je crois dans
l'ordre les pays des balkans occidentaux
sont engagés parfois depuis plus de 20
ans dans cette perspective où cette
négociation européenne je crois que nous
avons besoin là aussi pour les raisons
géopolitiques
d'accélérer le processus mais avec la
même exigence et donc c'est un travail
qui implique les deux parties si l on
veut que les pays des balkans
occidentaux puissent rentrer dans les
prochaines années dans l'union
européenne il y encore de nombreuses
exigences à satisfaire
des inquiétudes aussi que nous avons qu
on nous voit que la serbie ne s'aligne
pas sur les sanctions européennes est
évident que ça doit être un préalable
indispensable à une adhésion à notre
projet politique et notre famille
politique mais il était important aussi
de donner ce geste de confiance pour
travailler sur des coopérations très
concrètes en matière énergétique en
manière saine en matière sanitaire en
matière sécuritaire ou migratoires car
une partie de sécurité se joue dans
cette région mais pour dire que nous
étions disponibles pour poursuivre ou
accélérer ce processus d'adhésion pour
peu que les efforts soient consentis
encore par les pays concernés un mot
spécifique peut-être nous y reviendrons
sur la situation qui a beaucoup occupé
la présidence française jusqu'au bout
mais n'ayant jusqu'à l'heure où nous
parlons c'est la tentative de règlement
du différend entre la bulgarie la
macédoine du nord qui est évidemment un
préalable indispensable à l'éventuelle
ouverture de négociations d'adhésion
avec la macédoine du nord et l'albanie
puisque nous avons couplé ces deux
négociations - pour leur démarrage nous
sommes dans une situation de progrès
puisqu'il ya eu un vote au parlement
bulgare la semaine dernière qui a permis
d'accepter un certain nombre de
propositions que la présidence française
et formulé
sommes pas encore au bout du chemin nous
devons encore forgé un accord entre les
deux pays avant de pouvoir ouvrir le cas
échéant cette négociation mais je crois
qu'il était important d'avoir ce focus
sur les balkans occidentaux pour ne pas
donner l'impression d'un processus qui
ne serait pas maîtrisé contrôle et
prioriser et organisé je reviens quand
quelques mots à la question de l'ukraine
puisqu'au delà de cette perspective
d'élargissement le conseil européen a
permis de marquer un certain nombre
d'éléments de sanctions supplémentaires
contre la russie ou de soutien renforcé
à l'ukraine puisque telle est notre
politique depuis le 24 février il n'y a
pas eu de nouvelles sanctions décidées
l'occasion du conseil européen mais nous
avons dit que le cas échéant nous étions
toujours prêt à les prendre si elle
s'avérait nécessaire que à court terme
l'important était de vérifier que leur
application était parfaitement mise en
oeuvre et celles là où était aussi un
des messages des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement du g 7 qui a suivi ce
conseil européen et puis nous avons
indiqué notre soutien renforcé je disais
à l'ukraine
le haut représentant monsieur borel a
évoqué la possibilité de rajouter une
tranche de financement jusqu'à 500
millions d'euros dans le cas de la
facilité européenne de paix en
équipements militaires
le ministre des armées a par ailleurs
indiqué hier que la france était prête
dans ce cadre à renforcer son effort de
soutien en équipements militaires
la commission européenne a été invité
par le conseil européen également à
accroître ce qu'on appelle l'assistance
macrofinancière une aide au
fonctionnement des administrations l
état ukrainien pour la guerre qui est
essentiel évidemment à hauteur de 9
milliards d'euros ce qui fait je le
rappelle de l'union européenne le
premier soutient tous domaines confondus
est de loin à l'ukraine dans cette
guerre un point qui a été souvent
discutée devant votre commission
monsieur le président est parce qu il ya
de nombreuses dimensions c'est celui de
l'approvisionnement de la sécurité
alimentaire que vous avez aussi évoquée
je tiens à préciser je pense que nous en
sommes tous ici convaincu mais le ray
cyrus et parfois puissant que en aucun
cas les difficultés de livraison
d'approvisionnement alimentaire que nous
voyons aujourd'hui et qui pèse sur les
prix très concrètement ne sont liées aux
sanctions aucun des pays qui à appliquer
des sanctions à la russie y compris donc
nous et l'union européenne n'a appliqué
de sanctions au domaine alimentaire
n'ont aucun régime de sanctions il y à
une instrumentalisation des libérées par
la russie c'est la guerre et c'est
l'attitude russe spécifique sur les
ports en particulier d'ukraine qui
bloquent un certain nombre
d'exportations de produits ou de
compléments alimentaires et donc c'est
très clairement de ce côté là que serait
que réside le problème
il n'y a aucune ambiguïté sur ce sujet
nous avons développé à cette initiative
européenne où vous êtes ou
internationale à l'initiative dû prendre
la république pour ouvrir des voies
terrestres ou fluvial d'exportation
accéléré pour que les grands qu'ils
soient stockés aujourd'hui et ce qui
arrive après la récolte en cours ne
soient pas perdus et ne pèse pas sur les
prix mondiaux comme nous voyons
malheureusement fortement aujourd'hui
donc nous y travaillons activement avec
nos partenaires européens la roumanie la
pologne en particulier et puis au niveau
international pour essayer de soutenir
les pays qui vivent déjà au delà de la
question des prix des questions de
rationnement et peut-être de pénurie si
nous n'y prenons pas garde avec un
renforcement très fort de la
contribution française et beaucoup de
pays européens confirmé dans le cadre du
g7 au programme alimentaire mondial et
diverses initiatives internationales
notamment dans le cadre des nations
unies de financement de l'alimentation
dans les pays en difficulté cela montre
si je peux le dire d'un mot que tous les
sujets internationaux européens nous
nous parlons je crois que nous en avons
ici la conviction mais devant le partage
et ont un lien direct avec nos vies
quotidiennes quand on parle
d'initiatives de sécurité alimentaire on
parle des prix que nos concitoyens
vivent dans les supermarchés quand on
essaye de diversifier nos
approvisionnements énergétiques ce fut
aussi un débat du g7 nous parlons des
prix à la pompe cela ne veut pas dire
que c'est facile mais que cette
dimension européenne et internationale
est évidemment vital dans ce contexte là
je me permets de dire quelques mots
d'autres sujets qui ont été évoqués vous
les avez mentionné monsieur le président
à l'occasion de ce conseil européen
notamment des questions économiques qui
sont évidemment moins visibles
aujourd'hui mais très importante la
commission européenne la banque centrale
ont confirmé début juin que la croatie
rempli c'est désormais l'ensemble des
critères de qualification définitive
pour entrer dans la dernière phase de
l'union économique et monétaire donc
concrètement la zone euro et le conseil
européen ainsi confirmé l'adhésion de la
croatie dès le 1er janvier 2023 à notre
zone euro en respectant toutes les
exigences il n'y a pas eu le coup de
filou de passe droit mais je crois que
c'est l'aimant de renforcement
économique te montrer aussi que notre
zone euro à tyr et que en faisant des
efforts économiques et sociaux
importants un pays comme la croatie un
pays des balkans rejoint notre espace
monétaire dès le 1er janvier prochain
un mot rapide sur les questions
d'énergie je les ai évoqué à travers
la question ukrainienne mais nous avons
vu que nous avions c'est un des éléments
de cette crise des inquiétudes pas que
les inquiétudes d'ailleurs des constats
extrêmement préoccupant puisque la
russie maintenant a réduit directement
ou indirectement ses livraisons de gaz à
plus de 10 pays européens en violation
totale des engagements internationaux et
des contrats non plus n'ayant aucune
ambiguïté sur le récit qui est fait de
telle ou telle pièce qui n'auraient pas
été livrés c'est un choix délibéré nous
avons à court terme à prendre des
mesures de stockage renforcer un accord
a été trouvé l'autre il ya quelques
jours par dow niveau européen pour que
dès l'automne tous les pays européens
france vise même 100% mais atteignent
moins 80 % de remplissage de stockage
stratégique le gaz et nous avons
renforcé à nouveau les demandes à
l'égard de la commission pour que dès le
mois de juillet la commission nous
propose un plan de réduction de notre
demande d'énergie à l'égard de la russie
à la fois par des efforts de sobriété
par des mesures de précaution du type du
stockage mais aussi par la
diversification de nos
approvisionnements en gaz la commission
européenne a coordonné un certain nombre
de ces achats je pense un achat
supplémentaire est que les états unis
d'amérique mais nous avons des mesures
nationales et européennes à prendre à
cet égard pour ne pas nous mettre en
risque pour l'hiver prochain il n'y a
pas de risque à court terme mais nous
devons nous préparer pour le prochain
hiver enfin parce que il est important
malgré la situation et son menu déjà
copieux de mesures de réaction apprendre
que nous projetions sur l'avenir de
notre union européenne vous le savez un
exercice vous avez participé vous même
monsieur le président ainsi que
plusieurs parlementaires assez la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe qui
s'est conclu le 9 mai dernier en
présence de la présidente du parlement
aux pleins de la présidente de la
commission open du présent de la
république d'un exercice citoyen inédit
avec plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes qui se sont impliquées des
centaines de milliers de contributions
et à la fin 50 propositions plus de 300
mesures qui ont été proposées qui
d'ailleurs correspondent soit en
priorité qu'on a évoqué ici en matière
de sécurité alimentaire maintien de
renforcement de la défense européenne
nous sommes maintenant entrés dans une
phase d'action et de décision dès le
début du mois de septembre le plus
vraisemblablement la commission
européenne présentera dans son programme
liszt hâtif dans le discours dit sur
l'état de l'union un certain nombre de
mesures législatives
supplémentaires pour accélérer cet
agenda européen qu'on pourrait dire
agenda de souveraineté comme le
défendons depuis maintenant plusieurs
années
je crois que c'est aussi une bonne
occasion d'accélérer la tombe de
réformes sur le plan climatique
sécuritaires sanitaires et d'autres
réformes proposées par nos concitoyens
un tout dernier mot sinon je serais un
complet sur les relations extérieures au
delà de la question russe et du conflit
en ukraine
le conseil européen s'est penché sur les
agissements de la turquie en mer egée et
en méditerranée orientale les états
membres ont exprimé unanimement leur
très vive préoccupation face aux
récentes actions et déclarations de la
turquie notamment visant la grèce ou
chypre et le conseil européen a ainsi
appelé la turquie à respecter la
souveraineté l'intégrité territoriale de
tous les états membres de l'union
européenne et conformément à ces
conclusions précédente a respecté en
tous points le droit international et à
apaiser les tensions en méditerranée
orientale nous attendons ces signaux
concrets de la turquie enfin la
situation en biélorussie a été évoquée
évidemment le contexte que j'ai
mentionné autour de l'ukraine mais plus
spécifiquement le conseil européen avait
affirmé son soutien aux aspirations
démocratiques du peuple biélorusse ne
vont pas oublié et condamné la
répression qui malheureusement continue
voire s'amplifient de la société civile
l'union européenne a notamment appelé
les autorités de minsk à respecter
l'état de droit à libérer immédiatement
les prisonniers politiques nombreux
détenus dans ce pays je vous rappelle
d'ailleurs que dans les régimes de
sanctions que nous avons prises tant
qu'elles ont pris part dont depuis le 24
février aux vêtements le 26 février
la biélorussie et des responsables
russes ont aussi été visés par des
sanctions supplémentaires liées à une
application directe ou indirecte dans le
conflit craignant merci beaucoup
merci monsieur ministres de tous ces
propos
je pense que vous aurez peut-être à y
répondre dans les questions posées mais
dans celle que j'avais posé une question
sur le partenariat grataloup et sa
vision je sais pas on va attendre
peut-être le déroulé puis plus rien de
précis soit sécurité voilà
on va commencer si vous voulez la liste
des orateurs parce qu'il y en a j'en ai
16 inscrits ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on en prenne 8 pour pas perdre le fil
des questions vous répondez et on fait
la deuxième huitaine ensuite à commencer
par andré reichardt
merci monsieur le président seul
ministre je voudrais revenir sur le
concept de la communauté politique
européenne dont vous avez parlé
on en distingue naturellement encore mal
les contours mais une chose est ressorti
clairement du discours du président de
la république ce projet s'adresserait à
l'ensemble des pays européens
même s'il a d'abord été imaginé en
réponse à l'acte candidature de
l'ukraine de la moldavie et de la
géorgie or ces pays ces derniers pays
sont au même titre que l'arménie et
l'azerbaïdjan vous le savez bien lié à
l'union européenne par le partenariat
oriental dont on vient de parler le
président dont les objectifs sont clairs
le renforcement de l'association
politique et de la coopération
économique entre l'union européenne et
ses voisins ces objectifs sont proches
de ceux fixés à la communauté politique
européenne par le président de la
république
les conclusions du dernier conseil ont
confirmé qu'elle n'avait pas vocation à
se substituer ni au processus
d'élargissement semble-t-il ni aux
politiques et instruments existants de
l'union européenne dont acte mais on
peut s'interroger à quel niveau se
situera alors la véritable valeur
ajoutée de la cpe communauté politique
européenne par rapport au partenariat
oriental
d'autant que ce dernier a entamé sa mue
et vous le savez bien depuis décembre de
l'année dernière vers plus de
flexibilité et de différenciation en
fonction des spécificités des évolutions
des pays concernés et de nouveaux outils
seraient envisagées pour s'adapter au
contexte géopolitique par exemple dans
l'énergie ou l'azerbaïdjan pourrait
aider l'europe à sortir de sa dépendance
aux énergies le russe attention donc à
ne pas fragiliser par les projets encore
incertains la dynamique positive et les
acquis du partenariat oriental qui
malgré certaines limites a tant bien que
mal réussi à arrimer le destin de la
plupart de ces pays à celui de l'europe
plutôt qu'à celui d'autres grandes
puissances vous voyez de quoi je veux
parler monsieur le ministre on résumer
ma question est simple comment
envisagez-vous l'articulation entre le
partenariat existant et la communauté à
venir je dois dire que ce ministre je
procède tout à l'heure à des auditions
pour la commission des lois à 14h36 je
n'étais plus là au moment de votre
réponse veuillez m'en excuser mais
naturellement je serai très attentif aux
conclusions que vous nous donnerez
merci au président remercie monsieur le
ministre
je vais bien évidemment revenir sur une
bonne part de vos propos puisque en
décidant d'accorder à l'ukraine et la
moldavie le statut de pays candidat et
en reconnaissant la perspective
européenne de la georgie le conseil
européen effectué un geste politique
très fort à l'égard de ces pays et dans
le même temps en tenant une réunion
préalable avec les pays des balkans
occidentaux
le conseil a marqué sa volonté de
poursuivre la politique d'élargissement
dans un contexte géopolitique qui
pourrait les inquiéter
cette décision est une marque symbolique
et politique de confiance envers la
capacité de ces pays à progresser pour
remplir les critères définis bénagues
c'est aussi un acte de foi dans la
capacité de l'union à intégrer nouveau
membre auquel elle n'était lié jusqu'à
présent que par des accords
d'association et de libre échange dans
le cadre du partenariat oriental que mon
collègue vient de mentionner et dans
lequel aussi la politique européenne de
voisinage
ce partenariat demeure valide mais
change de dimension d'où ma question qui
est triple pour la première fois de son
histoire
l'élargissement de l'union européenne
pourrait-il être déconnecté de son
approfondissement
alors que le conseil européen je cite
prend note dans les mêmes conclusions
des propositions de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe dont il recommande
un suivi efficace là aussi je cite
un tel suivi ne passe t'il pas selon
vous par la réunion d'une convention
comme le demande le parlement européen
chargé de réformer le fonctionnement de
l'union européenne dont nous connaissons
les limites à 27 et que vous avez
souligné et qui ne peuvent être
franchies au prochain élargissement dans
l'intervalle un autour de vous
interroger sur le contenu concret
regard du discours du président la
république du 9 mai dernier de la
communauté politique européenne qu'il
appelle de ses voeux pour tisser avec
tous les pays européens voisins des
solidarités de fait des coopérations
tangible je le cite là aussi
de telle sorte que l'on soit en capacité
clairement de définir s'il s'agit d'une
salle d'attenté d'un partenariat
renforcé alors que d'autres puissances
étaient aussi dit par henri un char tout
à l'heure un accueil très avisé et
regarde de très près ce qui se passe
dans ces pays
merci didier alors en visio nous avons
véronique guillotin
oui merci je sais pas ce que vous
entendez bien très bien véronique ok
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre comme cela a été rappelé et
donc par vous même et une présidence la
décision à l'unanimité d'accorder le
statut de pays candidat l'ukraine et la
moldavie a été le fait marquant du
conseil européen des 23 et 24 juin
je crois en effet qu'il est important
que l'union européenne soutienne
l'ukraine et la moldavie dans le
contexte que nous connaissons et ma
question ici d'apporter plus
particulièrement sur la moldavie la
présidente de la république moldave a
été élu en effet sur un programme
courageux de lutte contre la corruption
et de réforme de la justice avec comme
objectif un rapprochement avec les
standards européens là des moyens de la
soutenir et faire mètres de lui permet
de montrer à sa population des résultats
à la fois qu'on crée rapidement
perceptible dans leur vie quotidienne et
je crois que c'est un enjeu crucial que
j'ai à la fois perçu dans les différents
échelons par wordpress mais également
lors de mon déplacement club d'habiter
en mai dernier la tâche semble immense
que ce soit dans le domaine de l'énergie
du secteur bancaire de la valorisation
des matières premières agricoles des
exportations encore des réformes de la
justice je viens de l'évoquer monsieur
le ministre quel vous semblent être les
priorités à privilégier lors du
processus de pré adhésion pour orienter
le programme de soutien et dead que l'on
apporte à ce pays
merci véronique catherine morin desailly
qui est avec nous
bien monsieur le ministre d'abord je
tiens à
saluer votre engagement votre travail
dans le cadre de cette présidence
française l'union qui skie qui s'achève
et du dialogue permanent que vous avez
bien voulu mener avec nos qui va se
poursuivre alors ma question a porté sur
la politique énergétique de l'union et
la coordination des états membres où il
avait évoqué vous avez parlé des
inquiétudes des constats extrêmement
préoccupant d'un plan de stockage
renforcé d'un plan de réduction la
demande de énergétique ainsi que un plan
de diversification
de ses énergies maintenant je ferai vous
interrogez plus concrètement sur les
mesures que le gouvernement et l'union
pourrait prendre dans les prochains mois
pour remédier en réalité à la
problématique spécifique de
l'approvisionnement parce que c'est bien
ça la question les besoins en énergie
dans les mois à venir particulièrement
l'hiver prochain vont êtres vont être là
près de 40% du gaz utilisé par l'europe
via la russie cela représente à peu près
10 % de l'énergie consommée par l'union
et bien sûr cette dépendance elles
varient selon les états les états
membres chacun étant maître sith son
bouquet énergétique et
j'ajoute que les pays membres de l'union
producteurs de gaz ont des ressources
qui dès qu'une fortement et ne peuvent
pas ne peut non plus forcément augmenter
la cadence donc en dépit des mesures de
sobriété énergétique possible
on aura besoin de gazon concrètement
quelle quelle action quel projet parce
que vous parlez de plans d'action mais
c'est pas trés les objectifs de l'union
sont pas très claires je prends un
exemple les importations de gaz
liquéfiés les etats-unis ont
considérablement augmenté au premier
trimestre 2022 on ne peut que s'en
réjouir elles ont été multiplié par cinq
par rapport à 2019 mais cela nécessite
de développer de nouvelles
infrastructures de transformation et
d'acheminement du gaz en réseau voilà
des projets extrêmement concret ce qu'il
est prévu justement de travailler sur
ces questions très précises
excellente question par patrice
sillinger patricia
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
on sait très bien que la succession de
crises auxquelles a dû et doit encore
faire face l'union européenne renforce
et attendent qu'on les citoyens
vis-à-vis de celle-ci s exprime en
conséquence une forte demande de
protection donc oui la guerre la
mondialisation d'inflation et et au
virus face au virus mais moi je souhaite
vous a tiré sur deux sujets d'abord
celui du salaire minimum européen et le
deuxième sera
la reconnaissance du droit de
l'avortement au niveau de l'union
européenne donc sur les 25 pays de
l'union six n'ont pas de salaire minimum
tandis qu'en contre les pays qui
disposent d'un tel salaire les écarts
peuvent être très importants la garantie
d'un salaire minimum représente une
véritable protection pour les salariés
tandis que la l'élargissement d'un tel
salaire à tous les pays européens
représentent aurait une protection
contre le dumping social pour les
entreprises des pays qui en disposent
l'aboutissement de la directive sur les
salaires minimum était l'une des
priorités de la présidence française de
l'union
qui s'achève aussi j'aimerais vous dire
vous entendre sur le contenu de l'accord
qui a été récemment trouvé sur cette
directive est l'impact concret que celle
ci pourrait avoir sur les salaires
l'autre question porte sur le droit des
femmes et plus précisément les droits de
l'avortement l'actualité démontre que ce
droit est loin d'être garanti sans
parler de ce qui se passe aux etats unis
on observe régulièrement des tentatives
de restreindre ce droit un peu partout
en europe le président de la république
et vous même vous êtes prononcé en
faveur d'une intégration de ce droit à
la charte des droits fondamentaux de
l'union européenne comment la france
peut-elle vrai pour contribuer
favorablement à une telle intégration et
sous quel délai un consensus sur cette
question parmi les états membres vous
semble-t-il atteignable merci ainsi
patricia prend trente mille
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
monsieur le ministre la guerre en
ukraine nous rappelle cruellement que
l'alimentation peut être une arme
lundi remirent poutine l'exploitent avec
cynisme après un chantage aux
hydrocarbures sémard il s'est maintenant
lancé dans un bras de fer alimentaire
avec la communauté internationale
face à cela nous devons réaffirmer la
nécessité d'une souveraineté alimentaire
de l'europe nous avons nos propres
levier mais nous devons les adapter à la
situation géopolitique actuelle l'europe
s'est mobilisée depuis sa création au
travers la pac première politique
intégrer l'union opel pour assurer son
autonomie mentaires depuis plusieurs
décennies on constate qu'elle est
fragilisé et nous ne nous pouvons que le
déplorer ma question est multiple où on
est la mobilisation des stocks
l'ukrainien quid des contraintes de
jachère obligatoire prévus dans les
nouveaux de belles dispositions de la
pac et mais également les dispositions
du du pacte vert sommes nous en mesure
d'espérer que enfin que la commission
des européennes intègre les nouvelles la
nouvelle donne géopolitique et
géostratégique européenne l'europe doit
cesser de faire preuve de naïveté la
france est encore aujourd'hui l'une des
premières puissances agricoles de
l'union européenne mais sa balance
commerciale connaît une érosion depuis
2015 elle perd en compétitivité sur de
nombreux secteurs le plan stratégique
national
proposé pour 2023 des 1027 par le
ministre de normandie ayant été déclarée
insuffisant pour faire face aux enjeux
du monde agricole qu'en est il
concernant la stratégie farman fork qu
est il envisagé il faut se ressaisir
nous devons actuellement faire face à la
désindustrialisation notre pays nous
avons la chance d'avoir une agriculture
forte ne faisant pas de notre
agriculture ce que nous avons fait de
notre industrie il est plus que
nécessaire de mettre ces questions à
l'ordre du jour du prochain conseil
européen il en va de l'avenir de l'union
européenne de notre souveraineté
alimentaire et de notre indépendance
merci franck jacques fernique oui merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre une question en trois points
vendredi dernier des jeunes africains
sont morts lors qu'il tentait en force
et en nombre de passer la porte de
l'union européenne dans l'enclavé
espagnole de melilla
encerclés matraques et gaz et avec
parfois les blessés laissés sans secours
pendant des heures au moins 23 morts on
parle peut-être de 37
prioriser la sécurité des migrants
éviter l'usagé excessif de la force se
respecter les droits fondamentaux
où sont ces impératifs dans cette
coopération entre l'espagne et le maroc
qui agit en gendarme à la frontière de
notre union à une autre porte de
l'europe on l'apprend hier par l'anc est
solide du monde du spiegel et du
guardian qui révèle comment la police
grecque enrôle certains migrants
encadrés par des passeurs pour refouler
illégalement en bateau vers la turquie
des migrants donc l'échec des politiques
migratoires sécuritaire actuelle nous
conduit au pire et à l'inadmissible
n'est-il pas temps d'en sortir le
deuxième point c'est mon groupe
évidemment approuve totalement la
décision d'octroyer le statut de
candidat à l'ukraine et la moldavie
alors que de quatre longs mois de guerre
russo ont tragiquement banalisée
l'horreur et que la solidarité pourrait
s'émousser cette décision historique
redonne vigueur assez solidarité ce
statut on le pense les uns et les autres
ne doit toutefois pas être un
cantonnement dans une antichambre qui
serait sans issue pour des décennies à
cet égard quelles pourraient être les
plus values concrètes de cette
communauté politique européenne et
troisième point enfin l'union européenne
aurait pu être la première entériné le
projet de taxe sur les multinationales
en faisant de l'accord fiscal obtenu à
la c d e à l' ocde une réalité incorporé
dans le droit européen on regrette le
blocage hongrois à la fin de la
présidence française cet échec interroge
quel avenir pour cette taxe ne faut-il
pas s'engager dans la voie d'une
procédure de coopération renforcée pour
permettre aux états européens prêts à
oeuvrer ensemble pour la justice fiscale
d'avancé
merci jacques alors cyril fait le vin
aux visions je vais demander à nos
collègues qui sont en visio ou d'allumer
leur caméra en permanence ou simplement
au moins quand ils prennent la parole
merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre moi je vais revenir également
sur le fait marquant de la semaine
dernière à savoir l'accession l'ukraine
et la moldavie au statut de candidat a
lieu il ne fait aucun doute de
l'adhésion de l'ukraine et de la
moldavie prendra plusieurs années le
fait que ces pays aient eu aussi
rapidement du statut de candidat nous
prouve donc que lorsqu'il ya une volonté
politique
il est possible d'accélérer
significativement
certaines disent à des tables du
processus d'adhésion cela me conduit
donc à m'interroger sur la façon dont
l'union européenne pour optimiser les
diverses étapes de l'adhésion et ainsi
accélérer le processus existe-t-il des
réflexions ou travaux de l'union
européenne de la france à ce sujet outre
l'idée d'une communauté politique
européenne qui devra de toute façon
rester parallèle au processus d'adhésion
des pistes sont l explorer afin
d'améliorer l'accompagnement des pays
candidats dans leur mise en conformité
avec le droit de l'ue ou encore pour
phase iib faciliter la phase de
négociation qui se succèdent et la phase
de candidature
je vous remercie
merci je vais déroger un petit peu la
règle de départ j'ai demandé à jean
michel arnaud de poser sa question il me
l'a demandé parce que c'est une question
quasi identique avec une question qui
est oui merci monsieur le président un
ministre est cher collègue effectivement
madame a évoqué notre collègue la
question lille et j'ai effectivement le
19 janvier dernier le président la
république avait formellement lors
l'inauguration la présidence française
l'union européenne devant le parlement
européen a exprimé sa volonté d'
actualiser la charte des droits
fondamentaux l'union européenne en y
intégrant notamment le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
je rappelle que cette charte
contraignantes pour les états membres
mais elle est aussi de même valeur
juridique que celle des traités et donc
tout citoyen peut s'en prévalant en cas
de non respect de ces droits par un
texte européen or que constatons nous
depuis cette date roberta à mettre sur
l'avs eurodéputés de malte membre du
groupe du ppe a été élu président du
parlement européen en dépit de sa
position contre l'avortement la cour
suprême des etats unis a annoncé sa
décision de révoquer le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
laissant la liberté à chaque état d'y
autoriser sa réalisation ou non et
certains états membres tels que malte ou
la pologne continue de limiter voire
d'interdire l'accès à ce droit ces
éléments traduisant n'immobilise voire
en recul en matière de droit à lille et
j'ai pour les femmes européennes en tant
que membre de la délégation des droits
de femmes et d'égalité hommes-femmes
j'aimerais connaître monsieur le
ministre comme collègue l'état
d'avancement des discussions concernant
une potentielle intégration du droit à
l'image et dans la charte des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne je
crois que les femmes européennes
l'attendent à vous monsieur min
merci beaucoup monsieur le président je
vais
croiser dans l'ordre et ça j'espère
tenir le temps pour que le sénateur
richard puisse écouter la réponse et
suivre ses obligations ensuite sur la
question et ça répond aussi à une
question qui m'est posée monsieur le
président du partenariat oriental et de
la communauté politique européenne plus
généralement pour être très clair il
faut certainement pas que cette
initiative de la communauté politique
européenne ne sais pas quel sera le nom
final
soit une duplication de l'existant nous
n'avons pas attendu la guerre et la
situation actuelle pour avoir une
politique de voisinage des forums de
discussions parfois assez intégrés assez
poussé le partenariat oriental en fait
partie en revanche la conviction
initiale de la france et du président en
proposant cette réflexion sur la
communauté politique européenne consiste
à dire l'union européenne en tant que
ensemble institutionnel ne résumera
jamais ne couvrira jamais tous nos
éléments de coopération européenne donc
il ya une géographie et une histoire
continentale nous communauté de valeurs
nous avons ce débat au sein du conseil
de l'europe que la russie a d'ailleurs
quitté
qui nécessitent des coopérations
politique avec des pays qui peut être
pendant longtemps ou pendant très
longtemps voire éternellement autant
qu'on puisse le dire ne seront pas des
membres de l'union européenne
et n'avons pas aujourd'hui ce cadre
commun
partenariat oriental réunit
régulièrement six pays du partenariat et
les pays de l'union européenne mais pas
la même table que les états des balkans
occidentaux par exemple et donc nous
n'avons pas ce cadre politique intégrée
donc l'idée double et d'avoir des
réunions politiques régulières pour
discuter sur les sujets d'intérêt commun
géopolitique sécuritaire éventuellement
avoir par exemple un sommet de la
communauté politique européenne où il y
aurait à la fois les membres de l'union
les pays des balkans occidentaux s'ils
le souhaitent l'ukraine demain la
moldavie est évidemment dans une toute
autre catégorie des pays qui pourraient
être intéressés je ne sais pas s'ils le
seront mais comme le royaume uni ou
comme la turquie
qui pourraient partager un certain
nombre de mesures de réaction
géopolitique et une crise comme celle
que nous vivons avec la russie et
d'autres et puis d'avoir au delà de
coordination politique régulière et
d'une communauté de valeurs
des coopérations sur certaines
politiques
qui peuvent s'inspirer ce qu'on fait
dans l'union européenne mais
s'étendre à des pays qui ne sont pas
aujourd'hui ne seront pas des membres de
l'union européenne en matière d'énergie
en matière de transport en matière
spatiale on peut imaginer un stand de
domaines de coopération politique mais
aujourd'hui je crois que nous n'avons
pas ce format continental vous me direz
la vraie duplication risque est me
semble-t-il sera sera peut-être le
conseil de l'europe puisque nous avons
déjà une forme de grand d'europe
des valeurs mais parce que le droit
garanti
mais peut-être qu'il faudra se poser la
question mais procédant manière
pragmatique si la communauté politique
européenne se met en place si elle
commence à fonctionner peut-être qu'à
des formats qui existe aujourd'hui et
demain deux vont être fusionnées
rationaliser au trot je pense qu'il vaut
mieux pas commencé comme ça vaut mieux
commencer par se dire créant cette table
commune qu'est la communauté politique
c'est une idée qui n'est pas totalement
nouvelle vous le savez avait été
proposée par le président mitterrand
sous forme de confédération open
d'ailleurs
l'histoire veut que c'était en
tchécoslovaquie à l'époque que la
première réunion s'était tenue à prague
même et cette initiative n'a pas
prospéré pour deux raisons nous devons
tirer les leçons d'abord parce qu'elle
était attendu à la russie à l'évidence
ne serait pas le cas ici et parce
qu'elle était vue comme une alternative
précisément fermant la porte à
l'élargissement donc ce n'est pas ça que
nous proposons non plus c'est soit un ca
soit un complément pour des pays qui
attendent de rentrer en iran pendant de
longues années ou qui ne veulent pas le
faire et qui légitimement le veulent pas
le faire et pourrait coopérer néanmoins
avec nous sur quelques sujets
dernière chose là dessus parce que je
crois que le sujet est important même
s'ils méritent encore beaucoup de
travail pour le dire de manière un peu
cru il faut pas qu'on répète les erreurs
qu'on a faites avec les balkans
occidentaux ce que nous avons donné une
perspective européenne des balkans
occidentaux
sous présidence française en 2000 aucun
des six points occidentaux mettent
aujourd'hui rentrer dans l'union
européenne donc il ya malentendu
réciproque des réticences dans l'union
une fatigue de leur part de négociation
d'attentes même de la négociation le
voyons avec des conséquences
géopolitiques qui nous touche c'est le
développement de trafic ces
développements de mafia c'est
développement de filières illégales qui
touche nos quartiers le trafic de drogue
sera donc c'est concret là aussi et donc
nous avons besoin d'être là aussi
honnête si un pays comme l'ukraine jeu
et en a d'autres à vocation dans des
années à rentrer dans l'union européenne
ne laissons pas tomber en attendant et
donc avoir un forum de coopération
politique qui peut aujourd'hui apporter
un certain nombre de bénéfices certaines
politiques certains financements
certaines réunions politiques communes
je pense que nous avons intérêt à le
faire pour ne pas créer une forme de
vide entre l'adhésion complète ou rapide
qui n'arrivera pas tout de suite si on
le sait est rien du tout et donc une
forme de désespérance donc c'est en tout
cas cette intuition qu'il faut qu'il y
ait ce complément politique et de
coopération dans certains domaines très
concret je cite l énergie et transport
mais on peut en imaginer d'autres voies
là et donc si ça fonctionne peut-être
qu'il faudra je le disais demain mais
attendons que des formats qui existent
aujourd'hui ne se tiennent plus mais
pour l'instant il vaut mieux garder le
partenariat oriental en attendant
d'avoir quelque chose d'autre qui
fonctionne
j'espère que ça répondait aussi monsieur
le président à votre interrogation sur
ce sujet je réponds à la question aux
questions pardon de didier marie aux
trois questions
j'ai un peu traité la première mais
c'est précisément pour éviter
l'opposition élargissement
approfondissement complète aussi pour
cette communauté supplémentaire parce
que sinon on se retrouve dans le dilemme
éternelle que nous n'avons jamais
totalement résolue sauf disons le
franchement parfois sacrifier
l'approfondissement en dix ans la seule
politique de l'union européenne dans son
voisinage ils en sont son influence zone
d'influencé immédiate c'est
l'élargissement et donc à rien puis
l'absorption en quelque sorte je pense
qu'il faut un continuum et parfois pour
certains états je leur ai dit je le
redis peut-être la turquie peut-être le
royaume uni une situation durable dans
laquelle ils seront dans cette
communauté sans être forcément dans
notre union sur la réforme l'union
européenne elle et j'allais dire
d'autant plus nécessaire mais quoi qu'il
arrive nécessaire même si nous restions
durablement à 27 et on voit bien que
nous avons des dysfonctionnements à
corriger j'y reviendrai sur la question
de la fiscalité de la taxe et sur les
multinationales sans état et donc le
président a remarqué sur ce sujet
toujours sensible son ouverture et sa
disponibilité et celle de la france à ce
qu'on engage une convention est
potentiellement une révision des traités
avec deux précisions que je me dois de
faire une part je veux vous dire qu'il
n'y a pas de consensus entre notamment
de pour ce faire soyons clairs donc je
ne sais pas si nous serons capables de
lancer un tel travail
deuxièmement quand bien même nous le
lançons riom
il ne faut pas non plus qu'on attende la
révision des traités pour faire des
choses qu'ils réforment l'union
européenne beaucoup de renforcement de
nos politiques concrètes en matière de
souveraineté alimentaire en matière
climatique en matière commerciale nous
avons souvent parlé ici peuvent se faire
avec des simples le simple lice lation
complémentaires les décisions de la
commission dans certains cas où des
coopérations entre certains états
membres sans qu'on attende si je puis
dire le grand soir de la révision des
traités qui quoi qu'il arrive même si on
ne déclenche et assez rapidement
prendrait du temps
donc on n'a pas à attendre 5 à 10 ans
avec les
certitudes que l'on connaît sur un
processus de ratification pour réformer
notre union européenne et prolonger cet
agenais souveraineté voilà donc je crois
que je réponds ainsi aussi la question
sur la salle d'attentes le partenariat
renforcé je puis dire c'est un peu les
deux mon général
que nous essayons de mettre en place
pour répondre aux questions
de madame la sénatrice guillotin sur la
moldavie en particulier je voulais vous
donner quelques éléments d'abord nous
avons un soutien politique apporté vous
l'avez vous même rappelé je n'y reviens
pas à la présidente san suu kyi et
courageuse
avec beaucoup de pression un contexte
géopolitique compliqué défendre
l'engagement européen je crois que c'est
aussi pour cette raison que nous devions
pas nous pouvions pas prendre le risque
de perdre la moldavie dans son effort de
réforme et son engagement européen et
donc la reconnaissance du statut de
candidat était aussi un signal
géopolitique à cet égard mais en
attendant il y à un soutien très concret
la france a mobilisé aujourd'hui
plus de 16 millions d'euros de dettes
budgétaires et d'être d'urgence à elle
seule plus de 37 tonnes de matériel
humanitaire ont été livrés et quand je
prolonge ce soutien au niveau de l'union
européenne c'est au total plus le sens
cadre de neutre
si dans le genre s'ils ont été mobilisés
par toute l'union et nous avons organisé
vous le savez sans doute une conférence
des donateurs le 5 avril dernier à
berlin qui a permis au total en incluant
les chiffres que j'ai donné pour la
france et pour l'union européenne de
mobiliser presque 700 millions d'euros
de dons internationaux qui sont déjà
largement déployé pour l'accueil des
réfugiés pour le soutien à certaines
mesures en matière de prix l'énergie
pour qu'il n'y ait pas des prix ou des
manque d'approvisionnement tels que la
population moldave se retrouve en très
grande difficulté nous avons un effort
budgétaire déjà important que nous
sommes prêts le président l'a rappelé à
renforcer encore dans les mois qui
viennent sur les question vous est posée
madame la sénatrice mme morin dessailly
merci pour vos mots amicaux et
bienveillant sur la question très
sensible des achats d'énergie disons le
franchement nous avons encore beaucoup à
faire
dans tous les pays européens ont réalisé
que nous avons pour l'hiver prochain en
particulier des efforts très importants
à faire il y a plusieurs leviers que
nous devons actionnés de manière
coordonnée avec une coordination qui est
encore imparfaite la question du
stockage l'évoquer mais c'est important
parce que c'est pour l'hiver prochain
une des réponses importantes on ne peut
et on doit reconstituer nos stocks la
france fait partie des états de l'union
européenne quand une législation
contraignante et qui ont des stocks
rempli à près de 60% à l'heure où nous
parlons ce qui est plutôt dans la
moyenne haute ou très haute de l'union
européenne beaucoup de pays ont des sous
clans avaient au début de la guerre même
si des efforts ont été faits depuis des
stocks compris l'allemagne remplie
seulement hauteur de 30% ce qui fait
qu'on peut pas affronter des absences de
livraison des réductions de livraisons
russes en particulier je rappelle au
passage que la france est moins
dépendante ce que la plupart des pays de
l'union européenne à cet égard puisque
le gaz russe mais représentent que moins
de 20% des approvisionnements gaziers
que le gaz lui même représente environ
20% de nos approvisionnements l'énergie
contre plus de 30% en allemagne mais ça
ne suffira pas de stocker pour l'hiver
prochain il faut diversifier d'ores et
déjà nos approvisionnements cela a fait
l'objet de mesures nationales
parfois coordonnées parfois identiques
en tous cas de développement de contre
alternatifs ou d'infrastructures
complémentaires jaillir une
infrastructure complémentaire c'est
notamment les annonces qu'a fait encore
la semaine dernière la première ministre
avec l'idée que dès 2023 nous aurions un
terminal méthanier supplémentaire au
havre pour corruption réceptionner des
livraisons de gaz liquéfiés
supplémentaires il y a une mesure que
nous avons dorje d'ores et déjà prises
vous l'avez rappelé au niveau européen
de manière coordonnée c'est un contrat
supplémentaire avec les états unis
d'amérique que madame von der leyen
avait négociés collectivement il ya
quelques semaines mais on n'est pas
encore au bout de cet effort de
coordination c'est l'objet des demandes
de précisions nous avons fait pour le
mois de juillet à la commission je crois
qu'on devrait plutôt que d'avoir une
stratégie
qui peut être compétitive entre nous
d'avoir des négociations avec certains
pays producteurs notamment de gaz
liquéfié dans les semaines qui viennent
pour que avec des pays du golfe avec les
états unis avec notre pays nous
puissions renforcer nos
approvisionnements pour l'hiver prochain
et puis cela accélère aussi mais c'est
du moyen long terme notre stratégie de
sortie des énergies fossiles à
l'évidence mais soyons clairs aussi ce
n'est pas pour l'hiver prochain que nous
pourrons nous passer globalement en
europe si la france est mieux positionné
que d'autres du gaz à cette échéance et
parmi les leviers complémentaires il ne
fera pas trop chemin évidemment d effort
de sobriété énergétique sont importants
aussi nous l'avons dit plusieurs
dirigeants d'entreprises énergétiques
eux mêmes l'ont justement rappelé et
beaucoup de pays européens sont engagés
pour leurs administrations publiques
pour leurs collectivités locales pour
les citoyens et aux entreprises dans des
plans de sobriété énergétique
complémentaires je rappelle enfin que la
stratégie que de long terme que je
mentionnais la commission européenne a
souhaité la renforcer avec un plan qu'on
appelle pardon pour l'anglicisme riz
power ue qui est très important puisque
la commission dès le mois de mars avait
par la combinaison de ces leviers
indiqué que nous pourrions nous passer
dès l'an prochain si nous activons tous
ces leviers en même temps de deux tiers
livraison de l'hydrocarbure russe ce
sera fait pour le pétrole ce sera
possible pour le gaz si nous renforçons
ses efforts et totalement débarrassée de
ses importations de ses dépendances à
l'horizon 2027 mais je pense que les
choses s'accélèrent ont encore
l'allemagne a déjà dit qu'elle sortirait
en 2024 de la dépendance aux
hydrocarbures russes donc nous avons
besoin d'accéder nous aussi ses efforts
j'accélère un peu pour répondre aux
questions de madame à singer sur le
salaire minimum européen d'abord pour
être très concret que change la
directive d'abord elle imposera à tous
les états membres dont les six qui
n'avez pas de dispositif d'avoir un
salaire minimum
soit par la voie légale comme le faisons
en france soit par la voie d'un
dispositif de négociation collective un
dispositif conventionnel s'est ouvert
des pays notamment au nord de l'europe
qui sont très bien protégées avec des
dispositifs de convention collective
donc il ne s'agit pas de casser ses
modèles l'obligation aussi c'est très
important ce qu'une vraie obligation
d'avoir au moins 80% des travailleurs
dans tous les pays couverts par une
négociation collective et tous les pays
qui sont en dessous devront indiquer
comment ils dépassent cet objectif de
80% et je n'ai plus chiffre exact mais
je crois que c'est plus d'une dizaine de
pays qui sont en dessous cet objectif on
c'est un vrai changement pour être très
clair pour la france ça ne changera pas
l'existence de notre smic il est prévu
par la loi ni le niveau nous sommes très
au-dessus de la moyenne européenne tant
mieux mais ça luttera pour nous mêmes
contre le dumping social ça fait partie
des mesures complémentaires qui vont
tirer dans des pays à forte concurrence
salariale nous le savons dans le secteur
du transport routier ou du bâtiment
notamment en complément de la réforme
ultra les tâches et les salaires
minimaux les salaires vers le haut et
donc c'est aussi une mesure pour les
français de lutte contre le dumping
social et puis il y à des niveaux de
salaire indicatif qui sont fixés là je
suis honnête ne s'agit pas d'une
obligation même si j'espère que nous
irons plus loin dans l'avenir
60 % du salaire médian 50% du salaire
moyen pour la fixation de ce salaire
minimum dans chaque pays nous sommes au
dessus ses objectifs en france mais pour
les pays qui vont mettre en place ces
dispositifs c'est une orientation qui
est donné et qui fera l'objet aussi le
rapport annuel dont il y aura un effort
de transparence qui pourra exercer une
pression
politiques ou syndicales dans ces
différents pays sur la question de
l'avortement j'en profite pour répondre
en même temps en question de monsieur le
sénateur arnaud
il ya deux pays européens aujourd'hui où
il y a de droit ou de fait plus
d'interruptions volontaires de grossesse
reconnu soyons honnêtes c'est le cas
pour mal c'est assumer toutes formations
politiques confondues ça renvoie la
position de la présidente m sow larmes
et de fait pour la pologne puisque la
décision judiciaire de l'an dernier fin
2021 20 pardon a réduit à un très petit
nombre de cas les autorisations
d'interruption volontaire de grossesse
c'est donc nous avons aujourd'hui un
différend politique avec ces pays les
traités aujourd'hui ne prévoit aucune
compétence européenne en la matière et
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président avait dire en enrichissant
progressivement nos stocks nos droits
sociaux des droits fondamentaux pardon
puisque une charte a été adoptée en l'an
2000 déjà tout prix danse française nous
pourrions ajouter le droit à
l'avortement malheureusement l'actualité
américaine renforce encore cette
nécessité là aussi je suis qu'elle fait
transparent il faut l'unanimité
ça n'est pas acquis mais la charte des
droits fondamentaux elle même a été un
combat de plusieurs années il y a 20 ans
et donc je crois que nous devons en tout
cas engagé ce combat je ne peux pas vous
donner de calendrier ci j'interrogeais
nos partenaires polonais ou malte est
peut-être quelques autres il serait à
l'évidence réticente mais si nous
n'ouvrons pas ce débat ce combat
politique chez nous le gagnons pas donc
je crois qu'il vaut la peine d'être mené
en complément les initiatives nationales
qui peuvent être prises dans
beaucoup plus brève échéance bien sûr
j'en profite pour ajouter un point de
préoccupation vous n'avez pas souligner
mais qui touche à la situation polonaise
c'est que cela a des conséquences très
concrètes nous avons beaucoup
aujourd'hui de réfugiés ukrainienne qui
ont vécu des actes de violences
sexuelles ou sexistes jusqu'à des viols
qui se retrouvent en pologne accueilli
plus beau dire généreusement par la
société polonaise mais qui se trouve
empêcher d'un droit qui existait dans
leur pays l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse et donc avec la ministre
chargée de l'égalité madame leurs hommes
nous prendrons dans les prochains jours
des initiatives de soutien je pars
l'occasion d'en reparler mais je voulais
déjà l'indiqué devant votre commission
pour répondre je reprends le fil aux
questions de mesures mais nos villes sur
la question agricole et alimentaire
alors nous sommes nous faisons deux
choses en effet l'une vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur par ces initiatives
européennes et internationales
d'extraction si je puis dire des
récoltes ukrainienne d'abord dans les
silos ou le grain est stocké aujourd'hui
nous avons plusieurs dizaines de
millions de tonnes à évacuer et un
rythme de livraisons par voie terrestre
puisque la voie maritime reste bouché
qui doit s'accélérer très fortement ça
nécessite de mobiliser des opérateurs
ferroviaires
très concrètement des containers des
modalités de transport fluvial ou
ferroviaires que je l'indiquais vais
travailler avec la roumanie et la
pologne particulier pour accélérer la
capacité de livraison nous sommes en
train de monter en régime mais avec la
commission européenne nous travaillons
aussi et maintenant la nouvelle
présidence tchèque a renforcé ses
soutiens matériels en wagon en barges 21
pour accélérer s'est passé c'était passé
de livraison par d'autres routes en
préparant aussi la prochaine saison les
prochains stockage pour que nous n'ayons
pas de pertes plus importantes encore et
puis vous avez raison je répond ainsi à
la deuxième question je n'ai pas traité
de monsieur le président rapin sur
l'adaptation de nos règles européennes à
l'évidence le train la république
l'avait dit publiquement et à la
présidente de la commission nous devrons
adapter nos stratégies
dites de la ferme à la fourchette je
crois en ferait une erreur parce que il
faut jamais que le court terme écrase le
long terme et renoncer à nos objectifs
environnementaux en particulier ce
serait une erreur en termes de réduction
des pesticides en termes de changements
des modes de production nous en avons
besoin c'est aussi insultes souveraineté
alimentaire pour l'avenir mais des
règles comme la mobilisation des
jachères ça reprend aujourd'hui 4 % de
surface qui pourrait être rendu
disponible rapidement le rythme de
baisse de production dans certaines
filières ou sur certaines surfaces tout
ça je n'ai pas la réponse finale mais
peut-être et noah tête je crois
rediscuter en effet avec l'idée très
clair qu'il s'agit pas de rediscuter par
la fenêtre de la stratégie farm to fork
dans ces éléments environnementaux en
particulier mais avec un an une exigence
simple c'est que nous avons un impératif
de production ça je crois que ça mérite
d'être redit au niveau européen de
production qui doit être comme on dit
verdi qui doit être amélioré
certainement mais un impératif de
production un impératif comme disait mon
ancien collègue de normandie nourricier
et c'est encore plus vrai au regard de
la situation actuelle pour nous mêmes et
pour le monde d'ailleurs parce que si
des pays comme l'egypte ce qui importait
80 % de leur production agricole dans
beaucoup de domaines dans beaucoup de
production de base comme le blé ne
peuvent plus avoir accès aux exporté aux
importations d'ukraine
si l'europe n'est pas là en substitut
comme exportateur comme donateur dans
certains cas nous prendrions un danger
pour grillon pardon à risque pour nous
mêmes parce que ne pas besoin de faire
un dessin pour dire les déstabilisations
politiques et géopolitiques peuvent
résulter de pénurie voire d'émeutes de
la faim dans notre voisinage immédiat
non je crois que c'est un impératif de
souveraineté pour nos consommateurs nos
citoyens nos agriculteurs mais aussi
pour notre
voisinage le plus immédiat donc oui
c'est un des sujets qui est sur la table
sur lesquels nous avions intégré cet
élément de souveraineté dans la zone a
dit de versailles en mars mais nous
attendons aussi des propositions de la
commission pour ajuster sa stratégie
sur les questions que vous avez posé
monsieur le sénateur fernique sur la
question migratoire sur la question
fiscale
nous avons vécu à nouveau parce que
malheureusement nous n'avons connu un
autre il ya encore quelques semaines à
un drame à ceuta et mellila
avec au moins 23 morts
ce qui au delà de la relation entre
l'espagne et le maroc plaide encore
davantage pour une politique migratoire
européenne
c'est-à-dire des règles de solidarité
dans l'accueil des règles de contrôle
aux frontières bien établi avec eux un
code de conduite je dois dire que
l'espagne a engagé immédiatement la
demande du président du gouvernement
sanchez trois enquêtes qui feront la
lumière sur les faits voir s'il ya des
responsabilités à l'évidence et le
présent sanchez l'a indiqué dès le
départ il y a eu des passeurs des
trafics les trafiquants d'êtres humains
pour appeler les choses par leur nom qui
ont la première responsabilité dans
cette situation mais il ya une situation
très particulière de ces enclaves
espagnoles comme vous le savez nous
avons obtenu quelques premiers résultats
importants sous présidence française
avec notamment l'acceptation dans un
équilibre celui de la responsabilité
avec un filtrage des contrôles aux
frontières mais aussi et donc à
l'enregistrement systématique des
entrées sur le territoire au vert un
mécanisme de solidarité qui bénéficiera
des pays comme l'espagne comme la grèce
comme l'italie qui peut être
opérationnels déploiement renforcement
de frontex où les agences de l'union
européenne en général et financier pour
les contributions de certains pays de
l'est de l'europe en particulier qui
viendrait pour la première fois enfin en
soutien aux pays de première ligne comme
l'espagne aujourd'hui donc je
établissons les faits je ne me
permettrais pas de dresser aujourd'hui d
aucuns quelconque reproche à l'espagne
nous devons au contraire renforcer notre
solidarité à son égard parce qu'elle
fait face à un afflux migratoire qui
persistent
à coups mais qui est important et qui
est notre problème européen collectif ce
n'est pas l'espagne seul qui peut faire
face nous sommes prêts notamment via
frontex à renforcer notre soutien sur le
sujet fiscal qui comme vous le savez est
un de mes grands combats depuis
plusieurs années avec bruno le maire je
crois malheureusement devoir dire que
c'est mon seul regret dans le bilan de
cette présidence française parce que
nous avons tous fait pas seulement la
france d'ailleurs où tous les pays
européens pour obtenir un accord il
avait déjà été obtenue au niveau
international tous les pays de l'union
européenne dans ce cadre de l'osce et de
avaient donné leur accord est
aujourd'hui un pays landry bloc pour des
raisons qui n'ont aucun rapport avec le
texte lui-même
l'adoption finale de celui ci ce qui
veut l'interroger évidemment sur
l'unanimité en matière fiscale qui est
un réel blocage
en attendant ça veut dire que nous
voulons faire pression maximale exercer
une pression maximale sur la hongrie
pour que cet accord soit ratifiée ne
peut pas être pris en otage mais cela
dans le cadre de la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe et de ses suites
renforce la nécessité
qui sera difficile on le sait bien mais
de changer de mode de décision en
matière fiscale je crois que cet exemple
a fait mourir le débat parce que même
des pays qui étaient très réticents je
pense à l'irlande le luxembourg commence
à se dire que ce serait mieux les plus
efficaces en matière fiscale pour que
l'europe ne soit pas bloquée
éternellement donc en tout cas nous
continuerons à faire de cette et au delà
de la présidence à faire de cette
ratification une priorité européenne ce
serait dommage que l'europe qui a permis
cet accord international soit en retard
dans sa transposition sur la question
qu'a évoquée
monsieur le sénateur bel va pour
conclure
sur la question de l'élargissement oui
nous avons le souhait d'une nouvelle
méthodologie nous avons commencé à
mettre en place au début de l'année 2020
à la demande de la france nous avons une
mythologie qui permet justement cette
plus grande différenciation qui sera
valable pour tous les pays qui entreront
désormais dans la négociation européenne
d'adhésion mais qui s'applique aussi aux
pays qui était déjà dans le processus je
pense à la serbie et qui permet
d'accélérer si vous le souhaitez si nous
jugeons pertinents si un pays fait des
efforts supplémentaires il faut pour le
récompenser en quelque sorte donné
espoir mais aussi avec un principe qui
me semble indispensable de réversibilité
c'est à dire que comme on clôt les
chapitres de négociation peut en rouvrir
s'il y avait une dégradation de la
situation c'est à mon sens parfaitement
logique et en matière d'état de droit de
développement de la corruption il faut
que ce processus soit plus politique et
donc il accélère quand c'est bien fait
et qu'il ralentisse ou même qu'il
revienne en arrière quand il ya des
reculs dans tel ou tel pays nous voyons
que c'est possible aujourd'hui mais nous
avons besoin de donner cet espoir parce
qu'un processus d'élargissement qui n'a
pas de perspective qui n'a pas d'avancer
c'est un processus d'élargissement qui
est contre-productif pour tous parce
qu'on crée du désespoir dans les
sociétés des balkans occidentaux des
interrogations dans les nôtres pense
qu'il vaut mieux assumer ses
élargissements bien construit et
permettre l'accélération si nécessaire
le recul si besoin plutôt que les enlisé
dans un processus
technocratique qui désespère un peu tout
le monde les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement sont revenus sur la
conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe comme j'avais
ok tout à l'heure qui a livré ses
résultats au mois de mai alors je ne
reviendrai pas sur les modalités de
fonctionnement de l'exercice mais je
m'interroge tout de même sur sa
représentativité
et sur sa capacité à traduire sans
filtre ni cadre préétabli la réalité de
ce qu'attendent réellement nos
concitoyens
en effet alors que la guerre a éclaté
sur le territoire robin alors que le les
prix s'envolent et que les risques d'une
crise économique et sociale majeure se
précise jour après jour j'ai sincèrement
beaucoup de mal à croire que des
questions comme celle de la majorité
qualifiée au conseil
ou du droit d'initiative du parlement
européen je rappelle que c'est la
commission qui a l'initiative
législative
soit au coeur des préoccupations
citoyennes je pense qu'aujourd'hui il
tuait qui pensent à autre chose et
pourtant elle figure en bonne place dans
les recommandations de la conférence et
le président de la république n'a pas
attendu pour engager dès son discours du
9 mai la voix de la france en soutien à
un processus de révision des traités que
vous avez évoqué de twitter
le même jour c'est pour le moins rapide
d'ailleurs entre parenthèses 13 est un
membre par mois ont adressé une fin de
non recevoir à ce projet laissant assez
explicitement entendre qu'il le
considérait comme une perte de temps et
d'énergie
il estime à raison que beaucoup peut
être fait à traiter constants pour
répondre aux attentes réelles des
citoyens monsieur le ministre lors de
leurs discussions les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont ils laissé entrouverte
une porte pour une éventuelle réforme
institutionnelle où peut-on d'ores et
déjà estimé le sujet clos pour l'instant
et dans ces conditions la révision des
traités est elle toujours un objectif
poursuivi par les autorités françaises
par votre gouvernement et par le
président de la république et si oui
quel compte quel contenu entendez-vous
loeffler données merci alain patrice
joly
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre permettez moi de poursuivre la
question de jacques fernique sur la
taxation sur l'unanimité et sur l'état
de droit pour revenir sur l'impôt sur
les sur les bénéfices des
multinationales dont le taux avait été
envisagé à 15% beaucoup considéraient
que c'est déjà un taux insuffisant
néanmoins c'est un taux qui permettait
de des super matches en estimation de
percevoir entre 50 et 60 millions
d'euros ce qui n'est pas rien c'est
entre un tiers et un quart du budget de
l'union européenne
hors plan de relance bien sûr c'est la
fois participé à la conception d'une
nouvelle génération de recherche de
ressources pour l'europe mais également
participe à l'équité fiscale lever tôt
le véto hongrois est d'autant plus
étonnant que l'année dernière le
gouvernement hongrois avait adopté cette
cette taxe dans le cadre de l' ocde et
donc se pose la question de ce trade de
l'unanimité qui permet en fait tous les
chantages l'avait un peu évoquée dans
votre réponse précédente
l'unanimité n'en perd m'empêche
d'avancer sur cette question
fondamentale de l'est de l'état de droit
quelles perspectives sur l'évolution de
cette règle et sur l'élargissement les
rugissements éventuelle des sujets qui
pourraient être pris à la majorité
qualifiée certes c'est un sujet
compliqué mais aujourd'hui face aux
enjeux forts socio économique climatique
show politique ou encore financier
l'europe ne peut pas se permettre d'être
faible concitoyens ont besoin de se
sentir
on s'en tire une europe forte qui les
protègent et qui a les moyens d'agir
donc pour conclure monsieur le ministre
cette présence française s'achevant
qu'un accord n'a vu le jour à ce sujet
qui aurait pourtant permis d'avancer sur
une réforme fiscale mondiale d'une
certaine manière qui n'a jamais été
tenté jusqu'à ce jour capable d'apporter
un coup d'arrêt aux paradis fiscaux et
aux stratégies dumping fiscal alors
qu'ont été les sujets de négociation ces
derniers jours avec avec la
hongrie
comment peut-on sortir de l'impasse
quels ont été les réponses apportées
qu'est-ce qui a été jugée insuffisante
pour landry et puis une question plus
générale d'ailleurs vous avez commencé à
aborder la réponse quel avenir pour
cette taxe est donc à délai
alors machtens idrac en visio martin
bonjour président merci monsieur le
ministre ne serais pas étonné que ma
question porte sur les balkans
occidentaux qui ce que je préside le
groupe d'amitié ici au sénat des balkans
occidentaux et vous avez en effet en
préambule rappelé l'engagement massif
qui a été exprimé par le conseil
européen soutient évidemment à l'ukraine
le statut de pays candidat qui lui est
reconnue ainsi qu'à la mode à lui la
perspective européenne aussi de la
georgie tout ça ce sont des gestes
politiques très fort
toutefois on attendait aussi de la
présidence française avant même
l'agression russe en ukraine un geste
fort à l'égard des pays des balkans
occidentaux
cette attente était d'autant plus forte
que ses skis c'est évidemment le geste à
l'égard de l'ukraine et de la moldavie
il que la nouvelle méthodologie dont
vous avez parlé dans certaines de vos
réponses qui a été adoptée effectivement
2000 par l'initiative de la france est
censée justement vous rassurer sur ce
processus puisse il ya l'aspect
réversibilité qui a été introduite dans
cette méthodologie vous avez également
rappelé le sommet qui était envisagée à
cet effet mais qui est devenue depuis en
langage bruxellois une réunion de
dirigeants est prêt union à laquelle les
chefs d'état des gouvernements donc des
balkans ont bien été conviés je
souhaitais aussi rappelé avant de vous
poser mes questions sur le ministre que
la serbie est candidat depuis 2012 le
monténégro depuis 2010 la macédoine du
nord est suspendu à la levée des
obstacles qui demeurent avec la bulgarie
la bosnie herzégovine ou vont avoir lieu
des élections générales en octobre et le
kosovo qui n'est toujours pas reconnue
par belgrade attendent en fait une
confirmation de leur potentialité
européenne je dois reconnaître aussi que
la france n'a pas ménagé ses efforts
pour aplanir le différend il se tenait
historique entre la macédoine du nord la
bulgarie dont d'ailleurs l'assemblée
nationale a voté depuis depuis pour la
solution proposée par la présidence
française qui doit encore être acceptée
évidemment par skopje cela doit être
souligné mais pour le reste tout en
réaffirmant et je si l'attachement
totale et sans équivoque de conseil
européen la perspective de l'adhésion en
appelant aussi à accélérer le processus
et concussion donne l'impression quand
même que cette région demeure au milieu
du lié entre l'avancée politique en
faveur de l'ukraine et de la moldavie et
le surplace des pays engagés de longue
date dans un processus long et difficile
comment dans ces conditions rayons dorés
les aspirations européennes de ses
peuples sachant que les peuples et les
gouvernements de ces états sont en
attente de signaux beaucoup plus fort de
l'union européenne je crois que vous
l'avez également rappelé aussi mais deux
questions monsieur le ministre comment
la france et l'union rebelles houthi
traduire la romanité que font ses yeux
rouvert d'accélérer le processus
d'adhésion la question vous a peut-être
été déjà posée différemment mais je
souhaiterais vous ré entendre là dessus
est également comment la communauté
politique européenne souhaitée par le
président de la république cohabitera en
réalité avec ce processus
d'élargissement je vous remercie merci
martin daniel grémillet
oui messieurs prévue le ministre shah
collègues je voudrais revenir sur
l'envolée des prix des énergies et se
transmet désormais à tous les secteurs
de l'économie commence à mettre sous
pression les budgets des états notamment
les plus endettés mais aussi la
cohérence de la zone euro plusieurs
options sur la table pour tenter d'y
répondre de manière plus robuste que la
modeste boîte à outils proposés jusque
là je donc je compléterai la question
qu'a posée vraiment mon collègue
jean-michel ou le gat sur la partie
notamment électricité il ya notamment
l'idée de la réforme du marché européen
d'électricité et de son découplage du
prix du gaz
bien une réversion une révision du
principe du coût marginal
le sujet semble avoir une nouvelle fois
progressé la semaine dernière et la
commission serait désormais mandaté pour
travailler sur les modalités de marché
alternatif la discussion reprendra en
octobre au niveau des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mais pouvez-vous nous
éclairer sur l'évolution des états
membres notamment du nord à ce sujet
al'inverse il principe du coût marginal
n'était pas révisée quel est votre point
de vue sur les autres dispositions
évoquées par la serre tels que l'essor
des contrats de long terme la
félicitation des interconnexions la
promotion des flexibilités ou
l'introduction de mesures ciblées et
puis concernant énergie comment parler
d'énergie sans évoquer le sort réservé
au nucléaire dans la taxonomie des
investissements durables alors que le
compromis proposé par la commission
semblait devoir s'imposer l'examen du
projet d'acte délégué au parlement
européen semble plus difficile en effet
des commissions des affaires économiques
et du développement durable du parlement
européen ont voté contre ce projet le 14
juin le parlement européen se prononcera
en séance
plénière le 7 juillet l'issue de ce vote
absolument cruciale pour notre
indépendance énergétique
notre sécurité d'approvisionnement et
nos trajectoires climatique est
incertaine voulez vous monsieur le
ministre nous donner votre sentiment sur
les équilibres qui règne à ce jour sur
la question de l'acte délégué merci
merci daniel christine lagarde
merci monsieur le président alors je
voudrais revenir sur un sujet dont j'ai
été assez étonné en fait qui ne figurent
ni à l'ordre du jour du conseil ecofin
du 17 juin ni à l'ordre du jour du
dernier conseil puisqu'il fait suite en
fait aux déclarations de la banque
centrale européenne dans une réunion
extraordinaire du 15 juin au cours de
laquelle la présidente a annoncé la
création d'un outil en d'un nouvel outil
anti fragmentation outil qui a pour
objectif de prévenir une nouvelle crise
de dette souveraine dans la zone euro en
effet il ya une crainte qu'avec le
resserrement de la politique monétaire
qui avait été annoncée début
début juin et qui a été confirmé très
récemment par la bce il ya une
conséquence avec un des écarts de spread
qui vont se créer entre différents pays
qui ne reflète pas en fait la réalité
économique de situation économique des
dix des dix pays on l'a déjà vu avec le
spread par exemple entre l'allemagne et
l'italie alors hier après midi
christine lagarde dans un discours au
portugal a commencé à 2 a distillé
quelques informations puisque le nouvel
outil doit être connue que le 21 juillet
et elle a notamment dit le nouvel
instrument devra être efficace tout en
étant proportionnée et en incluant des
dispositifs de garanties suffisantes
pour préserver la dynamique des états
membres vers une politique budgétaire
saine donc j'aurais aimé savoir si en
marge du conseil n'y a quand même pas eu
quelques discussions entre les états
membres notamment pour savoir quelles
sont les réformes structurelles que
devrait engager les états membres
pouvoir bénéficier de ce mécanisme anti
fragmentation merci christine ollivier
olivier cadic
sim sur président monsieur ministre oui
je voudrais revenir sur la question de
chypre qui confirme sa place de premier
pays de l'union européenne pour le
nombre de demandeurs d'asile rapporté à
sa population
d'après les dernières estimations ce
ratio s'établit désormais autour de 5 %
j'étais à nicosie la semaine dernière
douze mille migrants sont arrivés en
2021 ils sont neuf mille est
comptabilisé en juin 2022 soit une
progression de 100 % sur la même période
pour le seul mois de mai où 45
embarquement frauduleux qui ont été
prévenus dans les deux aéroports
internationaux de larnaca et de pafos
donc on sait qu'elle joue dans que nous
constatons nous mêmes
la visite à chypre de monsieur chinna
smith président de la commission
européenne le 18 juin dernier a donné
lieu à une mise en cause directe des
autorités de la partie occupée de lille
et de la turquie leur responsabilité
dans les flux migratoires qui affecte la
république de chypre a été évoqué pour
la première fois ce niveau sans détour
le vice président de la commission a
ainsi souligné que des contacts étaient
établis au plus haut niveau avec des
autorités turques ainsi qu'avec les
opérateurs aériens turkish airlines et
pegasus en vue de les inviter fermement
à prendre leurs responsabilités
pouvez vous nous indiquer monsieur le
ministre quelles sanctions sont prévues
envers les autorités turques si leurs
manoeuvres se poursuivent je vous laisse
c'est à vous je suis ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
pour prendre d'abord aux questions de
monsieur le gall sur le plafonnement des
prix
ce qui a été évoqué notamment au g7 je
compare le plafonnement des prix dans
plusieurs contextes et dans un contexte
réforme du marché européen mais ce qui a
été évoqué récemment c'est autre chose
c'est le plafonnement des prix pour
éviter que la russie elle ne profite
par un effet un peu paradoxal des
mesures de restriction comprenons c'est
à dire qu'en réduisant nos dépendances
la russie
et parfois en subissant l'arrêt décidé
par elles mêmes des livraisons de gaz
par exemple
la rareté fasse monter les prix et qu'au
total les faits économiques pour la
russie soit positif c'est ce que nous
avons constaté sur certains marchés
énergétiques qui bénéficie la russie
depuis les bulles et hier c'est une
réalité malheureusement donc une des
pistes mais elle n'a pas été conclue
conclusive évoqué notamment lors du g7
par les etats unis soutenus par le
prendre la république sur la question
pétrolière en particulier c'est de
réfléchir la définition d'un prix
plafond
alors pour l'imposer en tant qu'acheteur
pour ce que nous continuons à acheter
puisque nous réduisons fortement nos
achats de pétrole russe notamment et de
gaz aussi eh bien il faut une forme de
consortium d'acheteurs qui décident
ensemble à exercer une pression
suffisante à cet égard pour que sur les
achats qui demeure une fixe nous fixions
nous mêmes un prix plafond donc c'est
cette initiative nouvelle qui a été
évoquée notamment par les américains
mais aussi par la france à l'occasion du
sommet del mar lô qui s'est conclue hier
mais nous n'avons pas encore aujourd'hui
la mise en oeuvre d'un tel mécanisme et
c'est pour répondre à une situation qui
serait la fois choquante et
déstabilisatrices dans laquelle la
russie compenserait la baisse des
volumes par une hausse des prix
et nous avons les moyens de le faire un
mécanisme de plafonnement des facto mais
si nous sommes suffisamment encore donné
suffisamment nombreux comme acheteur en
tout cas l'essentiel d'entre eux les
pays du g7 commencé en faire partie pour
imposer ce plafond defacto sur le
fonctionnement du marché interne de
l'énergie électricité en particulier oui
vous avez raison c'est pas un sujet pour
la conclu sous présidence française
parce qu'il a été engagé
en début de semestre c'est la réforme
structurelle du fonctionnement du marché
de l'électricité je répond directement
aux différentes pistes qui ont été
évoquées aussi par monsieur grémillet
il ya quelque chose qu'il faut pas qu'on
perde dans une réforme nécessaire du
marché européen électricité c'est
l'intégration elle même et donc ça passe
nécessairement par un prix unique sur
les marchés de gros
dont nous bénéficions au total en
circonstances normales mêmes
circonstances de crise je rappelle que
nos grands énergéticiens au total ex
porte sur le marché européen ça
représente plusieurs milliards de
recettes
dont revenus économiques pour cette
entreprise par an grâce à un marché
européen intégré interconnectés
et donc un marché interconnecté
nécessairement à des mécanismes de type
prix marginal est ce que nous pouvons
faire en sorte de les encadrer d'avoir
d'autres paramètres à prendre en compte
c'est possible mais je crois qu'il faut
pas qu'on perde l'intégration elle même
avec chaque pays qui fixerait son prix
d'achat de l'électricité sur les marchés
de gros puisque là on casserait le
marché européen en petit bout ce qui ne
serait pas bénéfique je rappelle que
c'est aussi à travers ses recettes
budgétaires que nous finançons les
mesures de pouvoir d'achat vis-à-vis de
nos concitoyens en revanche et vous avez
notamment monsieur gré millet évoqué
plusieurs des pistes que là c'est
réaliste l autorité européenne qui me
paraissent à la fois beaucoup plus
accessible efficace et urgente c'est la
combinaison de ces différents outils qui
peut avoir un effet sur les prix les
contrats de long terme même si nous
savons que
longtemps des bénéficiaires si je peux
lui dire où les acteurs de ces contrats
de long terme s'était notamment sur le
gaz la russie bon on n'a plus tout à
fait dans cet état d'esprit mais avec
des pays comme la norvège ou l'autre
nous pouvons revenir à ces outils que
nous avions un peu abandonné ces
dernières années au profit de marchés de
court terme très fluctuants et c'est
aussi un des éléments de stabilisation
des prix parce que pour le dire
directement le but de tout ça c'est pas
tellement la technique c'est le prix au
consommateur
et que le consommateur ne subissent pas
de hausse excessive des périodes de
crise comme nous le vivons donc ça peut
être une des réponses ces contrats de
long terme l'interconnexion aussi ça
prend forcément du temps donc c'est une
réponse immédiate à la crise plus votre
marche est interconnecté plus vous avez
des chances
de bénéficier du meilleur prix en régime
de croisière
et fo notamment pour un pays pour la
france qu'un coût de production moyen
inférieur au coût de production moyen
européen c'est plutôt avantageux pour
nos grandes entreprises et donc à la fin
pour le consommateur français et puis un
outil vous avez de mémoire pas cité mais
qui me paraît très important aussi et
c'est là dessus que nous menons avec
bruno le maire n'est aujourd'hui un
espagnol une hache et un combat acharné
qui me paraît être une des grandes
priorités de la réforme du marché
européen c'est la possibilité de garder
les outils de régulation des prix aux
consommateurs
ce qu'on appelle chez nous la reine sur
le nucléaire c'est différent d'un pays à
l'autre mais la commission européenne
pour le dire très directement avait
incité voir conduit beaucoup de pays a
démantelé c'est un élément de
plafonnement de régulation on voit bien
ils sont toujours à leur disposition
c'est ce qui nous permettent justement
de maîtriser les prix en ce moment par
la crise mais il était parfois en voie
de démantèlement pays comme l'espagne
par exemple avait abandonné ces
régulations
économiques et pour les consommateurs et
nous avons besoin de les garder voire de
les renforcer et je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'il faut qu'on modifie qu'on
consolide certaines règles européennes
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent ce
sera un débat pour répondre à votre
question sur le calendrier que j'espère
nous pourrons conclure d'ici la fin de
l'année sous présidence tchèque mais il
nécessite encore
d'importants efforts sur les questions
en essayant de ne rien oublier
si j'oubliais et pardon la question de
ce québec
sur sénateurs sur les réformes
institutionnelles
je reconnais votre expérience nourrie du
parlement européen je
le conçois mais dans le bon sens
là où vous avez je le vois et plus pour
une fois nous n'avons pas les changes
sur la pêche donc ça nous changeait vous
et moi c'est le signe que les choses ne
vont pas si mal sur ce front là malgré
les prix qui augmentent alors pour aller
directement à la réponse je partage
votre idée que ce n'est pas il n'y a pas
des manifestations dans les rues
d'europe pour demander une réforme
institutionnelle se veut pas dire
qu'elles n'ont pas leurs intérêts et
notamment la loi sur la question
l'unanimité à travers le sujet
institutionnel il ya des questions très
concrètes qui se posent comme des
réformes sont bloquées
et le parlement européen ne vous
connaissez bien
met une forte pression politique pour
que nous ne lâchons pas ce sujet
institutionnels style sens de la réponse
du président mais je les dis faisaient
leur aussi je le redis plus clairement
quoi qu'il arrive même si je pense qu'il
ya des choses qui mériterait des
réformes le traité nous n'allons pas
faire de cette réforme potentiel avec la
réticence que vous avez rappelé l'alpha
et l'oméga de l'agenda européen et nous
n'allons pas attendre qu'une potentielle
éventuelle réforme du traité
interviennent un jour avec quel contenu
par ailleurs pour
dire très simplement faire des choses
utiles au niveau européen et d'ailleurs
je voudrais pas qu'on oublie l'essentiel
chez train rapin était avec moi dans
cette assemblée des propositions issues
des groupes de travail des panels
citoyens dans cette conférence pour
l'avenir d'europe portent sur des sujets
qui ne
non pas de dimension institutionnelle je
prends simplement un exemple un plan
européen de santé notamment pour la
santé mentale qui est un des grands
manques je crois une optique européenne
de santé budgétairement c'est très
concret s'est proposé par les citoyens
c'est une proposition numéro un dans la
conférence on peut le faire sans aucune
réforme des traités quand on évoque
aussi c'est une proposition très
concrète des citoyens français en
particulier l'idée qu'il y ait une forme
de dgccrf européenne pour que les
scandaleux agroalimentaire masse l'objet
dans quatre communes entre pays
européens parce que souvent les gens des
ramifications dans différents pays et
qu'on a peu d'efficacité en la matière
eh bien je crois que là aussi on ne
pourront le faire alors il faut une
législation et sans réforme des traités
européens donc je voudrais pas donner de
fausses images de cette conférence est
de ma vision de cette conférence
l'essentiel des choses pour ça que
j'évoquais le programme de travail de la
commission européenne et le discours sur
l'état de l'union doivent être présentés
notamment par la commission avec son
monopole à ce stade du tournoi
d'initiative au mois de septembre c'est
là qu'on verra concrètement comment on
met en oeuvre un certain nombre de
propositions d'accélération demandé par
les citoyens donc je partage cette
approche concrète sur les questions vous
avez posé cette jolie sur la question
fiscale notamment
pour être clair
il n'y a pas eu de négociations de fond
avec la hongrie sur ce texte puisque ce
n'est pas sur le sujet fiscal et sur le
contenu de l'accord que le blocage porte
c'est pour ça que je parlais de
malheureusement de blocage assimilable à
une prise d'otages c'est que c'est un
blocage tactique et donc nous n'avons
pas cherché à négocier le contenu
puisque le contenu d'abord il définit
essentiellement par l'accord
international ya des paramètres de
transposition qu'on a pu faire évoluer
bruno le maire a fait un travail de
plusieurs mois pour que différents pays
qui avaient des questions pour le coup
est compréhensible sur le plan technique
c'était le cas de mal ce même la pologne
trouvent une réponse est on a trouvé cet
accord quasi unanime et la hongrie ne
teste pas sur le contenu de cet accord
fiscal malheureusement si c'était le cas
on pourrait essayer de trouver une
réponse mais c'est un sujet
sorte de dommage collatéral d'une
stratégie politique alors que fait-on
face à ça à court terme on continue le
travail
il ya la question qui se pose
régulièrement d'une coopération
renforcée je pense que ce serait une
mauvaise idée de l'ouvrir maintenant
parce que ce serait une sorte de
récompense pour ceux qui ne veulent pas
faire l'effort tous les pays même des
pays qui étaient pas très enthousiaste
départ comme l'irlande ont fait l'effort
de rentrer dans l'accord international
et maintenant d'accepter le texte
européen de transposition si on leur dit
mais en fait je suis bloquée pour être
exempté en quelque sorte de cette
réforme importante on donne pas un très
bon signal pour des pays qui ont
participé à la négociation donc
peut-être que c'est une piste qu'il
faudra un moment regarder mais
aujourd'hui je crois que ce ne serait
pas la bonne option en faut continuer la
pression politique et puis d'autant plus
ça fait partie des sujets pour le coup
institutionnel mais on peut le faire
d'ailleurs aussi à traiter constant
essaie de réduire le champ de
l'unanimité parce qu'on voit bien à quel
point ça nous bloque dans les domaines
importants
pour répondre aux question vous est
posée madame la sénatrice de sidrac sur
les gestes les guerres des balkans
occidentaux et le rôle de la cpe la
réunion effectivement ce n'était pas un
sommet a littéralement mais la réunion
que nous avons tenue
initiative la présidence française était
aussi une façon de dire on avait prévu
avant la guerre en ukraine mais de dire
même dans ce contexte nouveau et même
avec le signal donné à l'ukraine et à la
moldavie d'octroi du statut de candidat
nous n'oublions pas les balkans
occidentaux et nous les façons ne les
faisons pas passer au bout de la file si
je peux dire je crois que c'est très
important deuxième point nous avons
réengager peut-être pas encore assez
mais ré engager des coopérations très
concrètes en matière d'accès aux vaccins
en matière de coopération énergétique et
l'allemagne a exprimé le souhait de
réactiver ce qu'on avait appelé le
processus de berlin que président à tour
de rôle qui est aussi un enceinte de
discussion et le financement de projets
d'investissement publics et privés
notamment concret dans les balkans
occidentaux nous devons nous réengager
pas seulement par le processus
d'élargissement lui-même mais par des
coopérations nous avons ouvert par
exemple du bureau de l'agencé française
de développement ces derniers mois dans
la région une présence sécuritaire une
présence du développement une présence
d'investissement économique il nous
fasse occuper le terrain si je peux dire
elles n'ont pas de manière agressive
mais de manière partenariale parce que
sinon vous le savez mieux que moi
d'autres puissances étrangères la chine
notamment la russie elle-même ou la
turquie sont très influentes dans la
région et poussent leurs pions donc moi
je préférerais que ce soit l'union
européenne nos entreprises nos agences
de développement nous d'investisseurs
publics qu'ils soient présents donc nous
allons continuer sur cet engagement
bilatéral et européen dans tous les
forums mais bien sûr la question
élargissement compte donc nous avions
besoin de redire au pays des balkans
occidentaux
vous rentrerez dans l'union européenne
vous pouvez le faire de manière plus
rapide si des réformes sont accélérées
en matière d'état de droit notamment et
si ça n'était pas le cas nous est ici
nous serions capables à l'aune de la
nouvelle mythologie de ralentir le
processus mais je plutôt le dire de
manière positive si les réformes se
poursuivent s'accélère si l'alignement
sur les sanctions européennes aussi ce
manifeste nous pourrons avancer dans le
processus d'élargissement
et je crois que c'était aussi un signal
de réengagement une bonne volonté
européenne qui était donné à travers
cette réunion je précise que la
présidence que la présidence tchèque
pardon à le projet de réunir pour le
coup un véritable sommet avec un peu
plus de relief encore et le protocole
avec les chefs d'état gouvernement de la
région des balkans occidentaux pendant
son semestre de présidence
sûr j'ai pas répondu pardon la question
du sein est incriminé sur la taxonomie
et sur l'acte délégué je ne peux pas
préjuger de ce que fera le parlement
européen je veux simplement vous dire
que le vrai rendez vous c'est la
plénière n'est pas le vote qui a eu lieu
mi juin en commission c'est donc la
plénière qui devrait se tenir le 6
juillet les états membres d'accorder un
large soutien cet acte c'est à cette
taxonomie pour être très clair nous la
soutenons
vous aviez eu l'occasion d'en parler en
audition ici même du point de vue
français c'est un compromis elle
présente quelques interrogations mais
elle préserve l'essentiel notamment à
notre filière et notre libre choix en
matière nucléaire donc nous sommes très
favorables ce qu'elle puisse être
adoptée maintenant nous espérons belge
eu un espoir
plus que raisonnable que le parlement
européen puisse
valider ou ne pas s'opposer en tout cas
à cet acte délégués lors de sa plénière
du mois de juillet avec des équilibres
en plénière qui sont différents de ceux
qui se sont retrouvés en commission
voilà je ne peux pas dire plus parce que
ce serait irrespectueux et
contreproductif d'ailleurs de
donner le sentiment de force et l'amant
parlement européen mais je crois que le
vote qui est lui en commission ne
préjuge pas nécessairement du résultat
qui pourra avoir lieu en plénière
[Musique]